you know hand matches to an arsonist and
you don't give power to an angry
left-wing mob and that's what the
Democrats have become they would turn
our country so fast into Venezuela and
Venezuela is not doing too well folks it
is time for us as Democrats to be as
tough as they are to be as dedicated as
they are to be as committed as they are
Michele which says you know when they go
low they go low we kick that's what this
new democratic party's about Eric Holder
and what could be a presidential Ron
campaigning early we'll see in response
to that statement Colorado senator Cory
Gardner just put out of a tweet that
says you have other party leaders saying
Michelle Obama was wrong when she said
when they go low we go high but rather
when they go low we kicked them this is
not who we are
senator garner pointing out that he had
and his family had some threats after
the Cavanaugh vote meantime the
president tonight is campaigning in
Pennsylvania tweeting out to party in
the White House for Erie Pennsylvania I
cannot disappoint the thousands of
people that are there and the thousands
that are going I look forward to seeing
everyone this evening even as he's been
talking about the hurricane and the
recovery down in Florida and the
continuing hurricane Michaels we've been
covering all show let's bring in our
panel byron york chief political
correspondent for the Washington
Examiner Marla is the national political
correspondent for the National Public
Radio and Andy McCarthy former chief
assistant US attorney and contributing
editor at National Review welcome Byron
let me start with you this is the
politics of protests or mobs or anger
and how is this all playing well the
Republicans are extremely on message now
from the President on down
it's an old message that's been used
against Republicans so many times
they're the Democrats are extremists
they're dangerous this is too much of a
chance they are an angry mob they will
take away your Medicare I mean this is
this is a very interesting campaign that
they have centered on and talking to
Republicans in working to to keep the
house they've had the best week or so
that they've had in quite a while and
they attribute most of it to the
Cavanaugh effect but also some of it to
the trade victory they felt that the
president faced down Canada and won and
made one of these deals that he promised
he would make so there they're still
scared they're very scared but they're
feeling better you know save from the
same sheet of music there Maura usually
Democrats are good at that but every day
it seems like there's something that
fits into this narrative that GOP is
great Eric Holder right you have the
calls for impeachment of Brett Kavanaugh
all of that right and every time one
Democrat says something like that it
gets blown up by Republicans Republicans
talk about impeachment a lot more than
Democrats do net net net but I think the
Eric Holder cut is really important
because this is a big debate going on
inside of the Democratic Party yeah
should they be Michael avenatti
Democrats in other words should they be
the left-wing equivalent of Donald Trump
fight back just like he does or should
they stand for something as Michelle
Obama would say higher you know they
don't know what which direction they
want to go there is a lot of feeling
inside the Democratic Party especially
in the activist base that Democrats are
too weak they're not tough enough
and what does toughness mean you know
and this is something and if they win if
they do take the house back it's gonna
be an even more tougher debate Andy your
thoughts I just worry that it's not a
4-week phenomenon you know we can't here
do anything more than then calculate how
does this affect what's going to happen
on Tuesday night four weeks from now
this is not a genie that gets easily put
back in the bottle it has the eerie
feeling of 1960s 1970s radicalism and
it's a phase I think we're just getting
into the beginning of rather than you
know something that's going to be able
to be contained in four weeks yeah
clearly and we'll be covering the
midterms every day for the next 27 days
I ask all the panels to choose a race
that they think is interesting for one
reason or another start with you well I
looked at the Arizona race because
suddenly it's more personal to me I
should assistance eminent cinema the
Democrat versus mcsalley the Republic
yes the news that came out today about
cinema is that she hosted Lynn Stewart
who was my
adversary in the blind shape prosecution
in the 1990s at arising out of the
bombing of the World Trade Center turns
out that Lynne was later on trial
herself for material support to
terrorism for communicating messages
from the blind Sheikh when where he was
in jail to his Egyptian terrorist
organization it turns out that the
cinema evidently promoted two of her
appearances at University in Arizona see
how that plays Mara your race my race is
the Texas Senate race that's incumbent
Ted Cruz the Republican Beto O'Rourke
the Democrat tremendous excitement among
Democrats O'Rourke gets like crowds of
50,000 nobody that I've talked to
actually thinks he's gonna win but the
thing is he's kind of plowing the fields
or fertilizing the fields in Texas for
what Democrats hope will be eventually
that state turning purple they've been
disappointed in the past but this time
they think they really are gonna make
inroads I picked the Montana Senate race
the incumbent is the Democrat John
tester the challengers a Republican matt
Rosendale I think it's the best chance
for a Republican pickup that's not
getting very much attention the polls
are very very close and Republicans are
waiting for a Cavanaugh effect they
believe it's going to take place and
they don't believe you actually have to
wait 28 days or 27 days till Election
Day because early voting starts next
week in Montana so if there is a
Cavanaugh effect perhaps when it is
strongest people will already be voting
I wouldn't expect I wouldn't be
surprised to see Air Force One stopping
back in Montana as well panel thank you
a little abbreviated tonight because the
hurricane